[Musique]
danielle darrieux bonsoir c'est touchant
l'évolution de ses spectateurs à la fin
de la pièce
oui c'est vrai ils sont extraordinaires
à la fin j'en vois qui me parlent qu'ils
sont très début c'est la première fois
donc on l'a dire que vous jouez tout
seul et ce pendant plus d'une heure et
demie
une pièce qui a repose entièrement sur
ses épaules ça doit être difficile c'est
très dur j'avais très peur d'ailleurs
mais j'ai fini par accepter et j'ai cru
d'abord qu'ils allaient prendre un petit
garçon pour l'oscar mais on m'a dit
madame non pas du tout
tu fais le tout est bon alors c'est un
dialogue ans cette vieille dame est et
ce petit garçon qui est extraordinaire
enfin moi quand j'ai eu le lille de
d'eric emmanuel schmitt j'ai tellement
bouleversée j'étais en larmes à la fin
laisse pas possible de jouer ça on peut
pas jouer ça mais voilà enfin bon ça
s'est fait comme ça et maintenant ça
apporte énormément à jouer à des gens
qui sont qui ont même eu des drames
aussi dans la famille qui viennent et
qui sont bouleversés mais mais pas
triste parce que c'est une pièce qui
donne beaucoup d'espoir est il cet
enfant s'en va mais pas du tout triste
il a beaucoup beaucoup d'élus appris à
croire que rien des titres ici c'était
l'inconnu qui l'était pas ce triste
puisque on s'en va la difficulté quand
même c'est on l'a dit c'est un monologue
et en même temps c'est un dialogue
puisque vous jouer deux personnages
comme vous fait techniquement c'est
difficile d'en bas il ya deux
personnages et même des petits copains
de temps en temps mais elles n'ont pas
grand chose à dire mais c'est vrai que
c'est un dialogue entre cette vieille
dame et ce petit garçon moi je pouvais
pas non plus faire une caricature parce
que c'est pas c'est pas un one man show
rigolo donc il fallait juste changé un
petit peu l'internation comme parle
souvent les enfants mais c'est le sexe
qui qui qui vous en sera les moi ça me
ça me pompe alors je suis épuisée la fin
du spectacle est joué ça se produit
c'est un oui il ya une tension terrible
parce qu'il faut donner les envoyer
cette espèce de d'amour qu'ils ont l'un
pour l'autre et et ses traits c'est très
prenant et je crois que les gens leur
santé moi je suis très récompensé enfin
très content que vous créiez quand même
encore le trou de mémoire ou c'est
quelque chose vous savez
apprendre ça tout seul il n'y a pas de
partenaire qui te souffle un peu la
grande soeur trou et là c'est tout seul
c'est assez difficile
il ya des points communs entre vous et
mamie rose
oh oui bah c'est à dire que moi j'adore
les enfants et ça me satisfont
bouleverse parce que on peut tout
imaginer
bon moi je connais les enfants j'ai des
petits fils j'ai perdu un fils et je
suis très enfin ça ma femme ça me prend
beaucoup ça me met jeu j'essaie de le
renvoyer
je joue pas pour moi je joue pour les
gens et je crois qu'on leur envoie
quelque chose qui est très qui est pas
du tout pessimiste qui n'est pas triste
risque de même la mort d'un enfant c'est
très dur il ya dix ans on va parler
juste un petit peu de cinéma puisque
vous êtes nominé suppression des nominés
nommé en tout cas aux oiseaux oscars la
semaine prochaine pour un second rôle
pour huit femmes comment alors je trouve
ça ridicule c'est pas que c'est pas que
ce soit pour un second rôle ça ça me
choque pas du tout mais je sens que huit
femmes bon on les huit femmes c'est issa
la grande plaisanterie et l'idée du film
est bon nous a donné le prix collectif
en allemagne en italie c'était très bien
au delà
je comprends pourquoi ils étaient
premiers rôles des seconds rôles
désespoir des machins au delà de ça vous
attacher une importance encore au prix
moellons allant politique non non vous
avez des projets encore d'aider des
souhaits après cette pièce qui va sans
doute durer jusque jusqu'au mois de juin
normalement oui je pense que je vais le
jouer jusqu'à l'été c'était normalement
votre dernière pièce vous l'aviez dit
même avant vous avez dit je ne jouerai
plus et puis oui parce que le tfc serait
prenant quand même c'est tout même la
vie complètement transformé ont la plume
on peut pas envisager de faire un voyage
même en week-end et tous est très
prenante et 1
et puis je me suis dit avoir parce que
j'ai trouvé ça si beau bref c'est
beaucoup merci beaucoup de danielle
darrieux
[Musique]